another day another about face from the
failed fourth estate
also known as america's media industrial
complex remember last june when former
president trump held a bible outside a
church
up for everyone to see that was
lafayette park right outside the white
house
there were days of breathless media
reports about the former president and
attorney general bill barr having
cops removed protesters with excessive
force of course
that wasn't necessarily true the crowd
control was not done
for the purposes of a photo op we know
this from a new
report from the inspector general's
office quote the evidence we reviewed
showed the park was cleared to allow a
contractor
to safely install anti-scale fencing in
response to
destruction of federal property and an
injury to officers that occurred on may
and may 31st this was another one of
those protests
the media told us was a peaceful one but
obviously not here according to the
inspector general's report the evidence
established
that officials made those decisions
hours before
they knew of a potential presidential
visit to that park which occurred
later that day the narrative we thought
we knew
is not the reality that was ken danlien
on meet the press daily
saying the narrative we thought we knew
was not
reality and how many times have we heard
that lately let's welcome in now host of
the reuben report
dave rubin author of the book don't burn
this book
thinking for yourself in an age of
unreason and we promote the book dave
because it's critically important now
because you've got
just a mountain of media
mouthpieces saying the same thing
president trump clearing lafayette park
using stun grenades because these
protesters were peaceful
and he was mad he wanted his photo op
and then
any catharsis again from you to hear a
guy like ken danlian say
the narrative we thought was true turns
out was false dave
anything there or just anger well john
john as you know i don't want people to
burn the book but i wouldn't mind them
maybe throwing the book
at one of these people because enough of
this nonsense i
you know me john i don't like to be
hyperbolic or over the top
but these people and when i say these
people
i mean the mainstream journalist the
corporate press
they lie about literally
everything there is almost no major
story
in america in the last say three or four
years or really since
really since trump and perhaps perhaps
even further back than that
that they have not lied if it fit their
narrative or they
ignore right so if you just think about
brett kavanaugh is a rapist and the
covington kids
are racist and very fine people on both
sides and the russia hoax
and now we don't talk about hunter biden
and the n-word because it doesn't fit
the narrative
they make up narrative stories we could
use these people in hollywood although
you know hollywood's pretty awful too so
we could probably just
redo the whole thing but yeah if if
something fits the narrative they run
with it and then they sort of half
apologize
much months later another one would be
remember just a few months back we
covered it together
when uh trump was on the phone with the
uh secretary of state of georgia about
the election and
everybody claimed oh oh trump pressured
him into finding votes and then of
course months later washington post
issues or attraction no that's not what
they did but nobody sees their
retractions and then we just rinse and
repeat
over and over i was going to say this is
uh you know truth is stranger than
fiction but it's not truth i mean
to your point of view these sound like
screenplays almost
um the way they're comprised the
narrative here
but you know i guess a better way to say
it it's art imitating life
and and i use art in quotation marks
because you know whatever
um you know it's a simple question too
sometimes i watch this stuff
and i wish i hadn't watched it i i feel
kind of like i need a shower after
sometimes but who do you think is worse
brian stelter or chuck todd when it
comes to this bootlicking style of
interviews
oh this is tough this is tough bachmann
and i've only had one cup of coffee and
i asked the tough questions
dave always i will try to think this
thing through no i would say
stelter is probably the worst
sort of in mainstream corporate media
because he hosts a show called
reliable sources and it is the most
ironically named show
in the history of television this man is
a democrat
operative propagandist on a democrat
operative propagandist network that
is cnn he pretends he's policing
the media which by the way is a very
worthy thing to do howard kurtz used to
host that show
on cnn years ago and i remember as a kid
i used to watch it on sunday mornings i
enjoyed it i like watching the media
criticize itself it's an important piece
of our of our narrative as a country
that we can criticize the media of
course
and by the way none of us are above
criticism john and i have no doubt that
media matters is watching this right now
preparing a hit piece on both of us but
stelter because
of the ironically named show where
basically he spends an hour each week
trying to figure out what tucker carlson
had for lunch
he's just the worst i mean chuck todd we
get it you're a democrat too we all know
you're a democrat but that's what we
expect out of nbc news stelter
takes it to another level and um you
know for guys who wear beards
chuck todd's not doing you any favors uh
you know you make it work
he doesn't i'm just saying it's just
it's just a fact i can say it thank you
i can say all right um you mentioned
hunter biden where's the hunter biden
coverage
um you know we can look past on some
stories that the new york times
felt that they really needed to delve
into like a 15 year old girl at the time
who lost her ability to attend the
university of tennessee for using a
racial slur on social media when she was
15 three years later somehow
someone writes a story about her and she
doesn't get to go to the university of
tennessee anymore
no repercussions here for hunter biden
you know
maybe the new york times covered it but
not like they covered this other story
didn't cost hunter biden anything
john this this story you know it takes a
lot truly to sort of just
really get me agitated but this one is
really something else because
new york times cnn washington post the
usual suspects
have all ignored this now look i
honestly don't really care whether he
said a bad word
in a text years ago and i don't like
policing language and all that but we we
know for a fact john if you or i or say
the former president's son donald trump
jr was caught saying the n-word in a
text
it would be leading the story they'd be
trying to figure out an impeachment over
it
and the fact that they ignore it you
know one of the types of fake news
people think that fake news is only oh
the headline doesn't match the story or
it's a complete fabrication
the most nefarious the most dangerous
type of fake news actually
is the stories that they won't cover
because
it doesn't fit the now buy here this is
the same guy who i think was
what was he snorting crack out of a out
of a carpet or something i thought it
was parmesan cheese
it was unclear okay he was trying to
find crack
but he did the parmesan cheese an
accident i'm sorry i'm just trying to
keep it all straight
that's why i always grate my own you
don't get that process
but uh but the point is john i mean look
they they ignore
things if they think it's going to hurt
the democrats and then it makes everyone
else
crazy because you know i don't know if
they know this over at cnn
but there's something called the
internet and on this place
called the internet people can see video
clips people can see pictures of things
people can see the truth well no no no
david i think they think the algorithm i
think they started to figure this out
because you go back and look for things
that took place in you know history to
you know when i'm researching segments
it's hard to find stuff
like uh absolutely you know the video of
the tank man in tandem square that stuff
is is is
you know straight from the internet
magically but you know
i think it's a very important point you
make these lies by omission
are sometimes the most costly we were
talking about this hydroxychloroquine
and zinc and erythema study that would
have prevented people from going to the
hospital that was suppressed
you know the wuhan lab leak theory lies
were lost as a result of these stories
being suppressed
and you know kudos to breitbart too
because they did a
kind of breakdown of 12 people who were
canceled for using the n-word like
hunter biden
we can talk about some of those names
country singer morgan wallin
nascar driver kyle larson michael
richard kramer
a long time ago was canceled for doing
this in a comedy
routine i mean you remember when it was
richard pryor and chevy chase did that
very
kind of oh yeah you know thing on
saturday live and that was like a show
you know watershed moment for this
country in race relations uh
and now here we are all these years
later and
some people can use the n-word some
people can't and that's not necessarily
determined by your race
no look you may remember i don't know if
he was on the breitbart list but you
rema
may remember kyle kashub who was one of
the survivors of the parkland shooting
and he came out as a second amendment
advocate while the rest of the kids
came out basically as anti-gun activists
uh kyle was treated horribly by the
media he still graduated number one in
his class
was admitted to harvard and then some of
the activists didn't like kyle
because of his gun at you know his gun
rights activism so they leaked a google
document from when he was in ninth or
tenth grade when he said some bad words
harvard then rejected him harvard by the
way they also reject asian people
because they don't want too many asian
people there so harvard is systemically
racist
but the point is if that is a national
story which it was that this parkland
kid
who's a who's a great kid by the way and
i hired him for the record
when he didn't get into harvard i
actually gave him a job and he's and
he's a spectacular kid
who's got a great future in front of him
but the point is
that makes news when a kid in ninth
grade you know says some language but
when the president's son because he's a
democrat
we pretend we don't see it yeah and uh
you know breitbart also did a breakdown
of kind of the scoreboard here when it
comes to the n-word usage the bidens
have 15 the trump's zero so for whatever
that's worth they went back and looked
at president biden's record when he was
in the u.s senate he used the n-word
you know kind of slid right off his
tongue it was in testimony he was
quoting somebody else
you can find the video online but again
these words are learned
and got off the top of my head i'm
scribbling it down right now but how
many democrats can we come up with that
have been in blackface
jimmy kimmel who's a comedian of ralph
northam what about terry mcauliffe
defeating you know democrat terry
mcauliffe defeating all the
minority candidates in the virginia
gubernatorial race to succeed the guy
who wore blackface as you indicated
there
you know anyway we are we are beyond the
pale my friend
we are and you know sometimes it's
liberating to be out here beyond the
pale because it's just so ridiculous
sometimes
um something else too they got a lot of
press attention you know
this poll seems ridiculous to me but
there's a survey out there
uh that claims oh actually we have
another poll this this one
i think is actually accurate that
progressives are more likely than
conservatives to ditch their friends
over
politics and you know this is kind of
typical with liberals like
you know dave i get a lot of you know
you meet a liberal you say hey i'm
john and they're like i hate you and you
haven't a chance to introduce yourself
yet
but uh they are always the the less
tolerant ones aren't they
well they absolutely are because their
whole world view
the lefty world view is wrapped up in
politics it doesn't have
sort of any verifiable truly
honest truth to it meaning a truth
outside of themselves so
generally speaking lefties wake up and
whatever they feel about the given
day whatever they feel about whatever's
happening in the news
and and especially whatever they feel is
sort of the reverse of what the trump
thing might feel like
is how they define themselves and what i
found as you know i was i was a lefty
and i've
obviously moved over to the right let's
say but what i found is that people on
the right conservatives
libertarians whatever you want to call
it basically because they believe in the
truth outside of themselves and we can
we can call that god and that's sort of
a whole other conversation but they
believe that the government is not
everything
right they believe in family they
believe in the cohesion between the
generations
they're not that upset so i can talk to
all sorts of people on the right and
basically
everybody agrees to disagree but i hate
to tell you what they're going to say
about me for doing a show with this
scary john bachman guy
on the scary scary newsmax i am a scary
guy
sometimes you are scary only man hair
you're a scary guy
i need a haircut though dave anyway uh
that's what my director tony told me
so we gotta run great to see you as
always we'll talk soon
good to see you again if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell